في برد موسكو لا يستعصي التدثر بادفئ
الملابس واحدث المنسوجات
لكن ما كانت يوما مع عاطف اسبانيه
وايطاليا غدت الان البسه تجهزها شركات
روسيه حولت ازمه انسحاب شركات عالميه من
روسيا الى فرصه لتعزيز حضورها في اكبر
المراكز التجاريه
في حجم المبيعات من مارس الى نهايه العام
الماضي بنسبه 63% هذا يعود الى رحيل
العلامات التجاريه الاجنبيه من السوق
الروسيه وهذا ما شجع الناس على اختيار
مصنعي الملابس الروسيه بحماس
حماسه يبدو انها انتقلت ايضا الى قطاع
صناعه السيارات في وحدات الانتاج التي
كانت ملكا لشركه رونول الفرنسيه ينتج
العمال انفسهم سياره خال الروس ان بريقها
خفت بعد انتهاء الحقبه السوفياتيه اما وقد
غادرت معظم الشركات الغربيه والكوريه
الجنوبيه فان هدف موسكو الان هو انتاج 800
الف وحده خلال العام الجاري
المصنع سياره جديده خلال سته اشهر فقط
وهذا انجاز عالمي والاهم من ذلك كان قرار
الاحتفاظ بعمال الشركه السابقه الذين
حققوا انتاجا جيدا
مثل هذه القرارات ساهمت في خفض مستويات
البطاله الى ثلاثه وسبعه اعشار في المئه
بحسب موسكو التي تضيف هذا الانجاز الى
نجاحات اخرى يبقى ابرزها تعافي الروبل
امام الدولار تعافي لا يزيح كل التحديات
التي قد تواجه الاقتصاد الروسي على المدى
البعيد فحظر 90% من النفط الروسي في
الاتحاد الاوروبي قد يحرم موسكو من عائدات
تبلغ 22 مليار دولار لكن لخبراء الاقتصاد
الروسي راي اخر
واضح ان موارد الطاقه والمعادن والاسمده
الروسيه الضروريه في الاقتصاد العالمي من
يعتقد ان فرض مثل هذه العقوبات سيكون
فعالا هو بكل بساطه مخطئ
العقوبات مثل السم بطيئه المفعول لكنها
تتسبب حتما في اثار لا رجعه فيها هكذا وصف
ممثل سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
العقوبات الاقتصاديه المفروضه على روسيا
لكن هذا القول يصطدم الان بتوقعات ترى ان
الاقتصاد الروسي سيعود الى سكه النمو
معتمدا على موارد روسيا الطبيعيه وعلى
اسواق الهند والصين وتركيا التي خففت من
حده العقوبات الغربيه ايمن الزبير الجزيره
موسكو